[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم بدات الامم المتحده اليوم خفض
حجم مساعدتها الغذائيه للاجئين السوريين
بسبب نقص في التمويل قدره برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي بنحو 350 مليون
للاشهر الثلاثه المقبله فقط وبموجب هذا
الخفض سيتم تقليص المساعدات بنسبه تتراوح
بين 304 في في كل من لبنان تركيا الاردن
العراق ومصر كما سيشمل هذا التقليص
النازحين داخل سوريا نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ل
نناقشه في
محورين منطقيه الدوافع التي حدث بالامم
المتحده الى خفض المساعدات للاجئين
والنازحين
السوريين التاثيرات المرتقبه على اللاجئين
والنازحين السوريين الذين يواجهون ماساه
انسانيه
[موسيقى]
بالفعل معاناه لا تنتهي اذا هي تلك التي
يواجهها اللاجئون السوريون احدث فصولها
بدا اليوم مع تطبيق الامم المتحده قرارا
بتخفيض حجم مساعداتها لهؤلاء اللاجئين
الذين يقدر عددهم بحسب احدث الاحصاءات
الرسميه باكثر من 3 ملايين وايضا النازحين
في الداخل السوري والذين يزيد عددهم على 4
ملايين
عنزي روح شوف معاق مخت عقليا شو يسوي
بحالنا اشتري اشتري
لاطي كان شتاء قاسيا ذاك الذي مر العام
الماضي على اللاجئين السوريين في دول
اللجوء بعض الخيام في الزعتر وسواه تهدمت
وكثير من ساكنيها امضوا واطفالهم ونسائهم
ليالي طويله يصارعون البرد والرياح
العاتيه الشتاء المقبل سيكون اكثر سوءا
هذا ما تقوله وان ضمنا الامم المتحده بدات
بالفعل في خفض مساعداتها لهؤلاء بنسبه 30
الى 40 في مما كان مقررا والسبب نقص في
التمويل يتزامن مع ازدياد مضطرد في اعداد
اللاجئين وتراجع في قدره الدول المضيفه
على مواكبه تزايد الاعداد والاعباء هنا ف
في مجلس الامن الدولي تدق ناقوس الخطر
توضح وتحذر هناك على الاقل 11 مليون مواطن
سوري اي نحو نصف عدد سكان البلاد في حاجه
ماسه الى المساعدات وتلك لا تصل بسهوله بل
بصعوبه بالغه فالخطر لا يحدق بالمدنيين
تحت القصف وحسب بل وباي جهد لاسعافه
ومساعدتهم ذلك ان عمليات القصف الجوي لا
تفرق بين مسلح ومدني في بلاد اصبحت فيها
المخابز جزءا من بنك الاهداف العسكريه ثمت
ايضا ما قالت ايموس انه اجراءات اداريه
يلجا اليها النظام تحول دون سرعه وصول
المساعدات الى مستحقيها وثمه ما هو اسوا
فاستمرار الصراع والحمله الدوليه على
تنظيم الدوله تسبب في موجات لجوء ضخمه
وغير مسبوقه فخلال نحو اسبوع لجا اكثر من
150 الف سوري الى تركيا وهناك احتمال باي
اطر عشرات الالاف غيرهم الى الفرار يضاف
الى هذه الماسي اخرى صامطه لا تتعلق بالحق
المجرد في الحياه بل بمتطلباتها فهناك نحو
ثلاثه ملايين طفل سوري لم يذهبوا الى
مدارسهم هذا العام وهناك كما تقول جهات
دوليه واقليميه حملات كراهيه ضد اللاجئين
في بعض دول الجوار وتلك تخصم من الرصيد
الانساني لممارسه لكنها لا تضيف شيئا الى
ر صد اللاجئين اوضاعهم تزداد صعوبه والعجز
عن مواكبتها يزداد ويستفحل
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفنا من اسطنبول
محمد صبره المستشار القانوني لوفد
المعارضه المفاوض في جناف ورئيس حزب
الجمهوريه السوريه المعارض ومن عمان مهند
هادي المنسق الاقليمي لدى برنامج الغذاء
العالمي التابعه للامم المتحده مرحبا بكما
ضيفي الكريمي سيد مهند ما معقوليه هذا
القرار وفي هذه الظروف بالذات ثم كيف
ستجدون الاريحيه لتسويقه لدى من يهمهم
الامر هذا القرار هو قرار صعب ولم يتخذه
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي الا الا تح الا
تحت ضغط قله التمويل نحن قدمنا المساعدات
الغذائيه للشعب السوري في داخل سوريا وفي
دول الج والجوار منذ ابتداء الازمه تقريبا
ولكن للاسف اضطررنا في هذا الشهر لتقليل
المساعدات داخل سوريا للنازحين السوريين
وايضا الى اللاجئين في في دول الجوار في
الاردن لبنان تركيا العراق وسوريا ايضا
هذا هذا هذا امر نحن مجبرين عليه ونتمنى
لو ان التمويل لم يقل ولم ولم ينقص علينا
وان اوفينا بالتزاماتنا للاجئين وللسوريين
ولكن للاسف هذا الوضع الذي نحن فيه اليوم
سيد صبره اذا المساله
ليست قراءه ليست تقدير ليست وجهه نظر ولا
موقف هي يعني هو قرار تحت اكراهات نقص في
التمويل كيف تقبلتم هذا
القرار يعني للاسف
نتمنى ان لا يكون هذا القرار هو فصل جديد
بتعميق الماساه السوريه عندما نتحدث عن
نقص التمويل العالم الان يتحدث عن حرب على
الارهاب ستكلف 15 مليار دولار ما نحتاجه
ما يحتاجه اللاجئون السوريون هو لا يشكل
جزء صغير جدا من هذا المبلغ الذي يقال بان
الحرب على الارهاب ستكلفه الان المفوضيه
الساميه للاجئين للاسف في الامم المتحده
هي لم تقصر فقط في حمايه اللاجئين
السوريين ورعايتهم وتقديم الخدمات
المفروضه وفق اتفاقيه عام
1951 بل انها تركتهم واقول تركتهم عرضه
لجميع لجميع الانتهاكات في دول الجوار نحن
عندما نتحدث عن اتفاقيه 51 هناك حق اصيل
للاجئ اولا في الامان في التعليم في العمل
الماجور ثانيا في الضمان الاجتماعي في
الانتساب الى الجمعيات ذات النفع العام
الجمعيات غير السياسيه في الحصول على
وثائق السفر في اي دوله من دول اللجوء
يحصل اللاجئون السوريون على هذه الحقوق
التي من المفترض ان المفوضيه الساميه
للاجئين تراقب عمليه تطبيق هذه الاتفاقيه
والبروتوكول الملحق عام 1967 نحن نستغرب
الان في ظل صمت المفوضيه الساميه عن اوضاع
اللاجئين السوريين المزريه في دول الجوار
واقول المزريه والتي تعرضوا فيها حتى الى
تميز عنصري هم لم يحرموا فقط من العمل بل
حرموا من ابسط مقومات الحياه احرقت خيامهم
في عرسال ومع ذلك بعد هذا الصمت من
المفوضيه تخرج علينا بقرار مبرره بنقص
التمويل هناك شيء اسمه الاستجابه السريعه
هناك شيء اسمه التخطيط الاستراتيجي
المفوضيه لم تطلق نداء كما يليق كما هو
منصوص عليها في نظامها الداخلي وفق في
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده لم تطلق
نداء من اجل جمع التبرعات اللازمه لتغطيه
الاحتياجات الاساسيه للاجئين السوريين
ماذا تريد المفوضيه انا اتمنى ان لا يكون
وراء هذا القرار دوافع سياسيه ودائما نقول
ان النقص بالتمويل هو السبب ا سيد مهند هل
انتم هل الامم المتحده وعي فعلا بتبعات
وتاثيرات هذا القرار خاصه ونحن مقدمون على
فصل شتاء وهذه يعني هذا النقص الذي قدرتم
ب 350 مليون دولار كما كان يقول السيد
صبره لا يمثل الا جزء بسيط مما يرصد
للاسلحه ومما يرصد للحروب المفتوحه
الان سيدي في في برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
نحن منظمه انسانيه انا لست معنيا بالحروب
ولا بتك فه الحروب انا انا معني بمعاناه
الناس التي ناتجه عن الحروب في برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي نحن بحاجه الى 35 مليون
دولار اسبوعيا لاطعام 4 ملايين نازح داخل
سوريا وما يزيد عن مليونين لاجئ في دول
الجوار هذا مبلغ كبير طبعا لكن نحن لا نقف
عند هذا المبلغ خلف هذا المبلغ يوجد امهات
اطفال رجال كبار في السن ناس محتاجين ناس
اصبحوا معتمدين اعتمادا كامل على برنامج
الاغذيه الع العالمي لاطعامهم ال الوضع
ماساوي وانا لا لا لا لا اختلف مع ضيفك
الكريم بصعوبه بصعوبه الوضع ونحن الذي نحس
في الوضع نحن نعمل في الميدان في برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي ونرى معاناه الشعب السوري
سواء في سوريا او في دول الجوار طبعا في
داخل سوريا الحصه الغذائيه السله الغذائيه
سوف تنقص بنسبه 40% لناس اصبحوا يعتمدون
اعتمادا كاملا على برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
ماذا تخبر النساء ماذا تخبر الامهات كيف
يخبر الامهات اطفالهم داخل سوريا اننا
والله لن نستطيع ان تامين المساعدات
الغذائيه لهذا الشهر الناس لا حول لهم ولا
قوه داخل سوريا في لا يستطيعون ان يقترض
من بعض لا توجد الاسواق غير عامره لا يوجد
دخل لهذه الناس داخل سوريا ناس مشرده شردت
اكثر من خمس او ست مرات يعيشون في بعضهم
في في اوضاع مزريه في في الشوارع وكذلك
الحال في دول الجوار يعيشون الناس في خيام
في في مخيمات او او في اماكن في في شتات
في سوريا في في ال في الاردن وفي في دول
اخرى وضع الناس صعب ونحن نقدر معاناه
الشعب السوري ونحن نطلب يعني من من جميع
الاطراف مع معاونتها في توصيل هذه الرساله
لل للدول المانحه لم لم نقصر احن نحن في
في في تفسير الوضع ونقل معاناه الشعب
السوري لكافه عواصم
العالم ولكافه الاطراف وللدول المانحه
اوضحنا لهم بشكل واضح وصريح معاناه الشعب
السوري وان الشعب السوري بحاجه لمساعده
ومساند ومسانده العالم حتى انتهاء هذ هذه
الازمه يعني بيونا ان نعرف يعني الخلل
الحاصل الان في دائره المانحين او الدول
المانحه يعني هل هل هي المسؤوله هل هي
التي تتحمل المسؤوليه في ما فيما
يجري سيدي الدول المانحه يجب ان نكون نحن
عادلين ايضا الدول المانحه لم لم تقصر
اكثر من مليار دولار عن طريق برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي تم تم صرفها على على على
في برنامج اغذيه العالمي على تامين المواد
الغذائيه لكن الازمه السوريه طالت طالت
اكثر من ما من اي من اي من من ما كنا
نتخيل ط اصبحت معقده واصبحت معقده جدا
تفضل يعني حتى حتى نحين الارقام في اخر
مؤتمر للمانحين كانت هناك تعهدات بمليار
فاص
ا للاجئين ولناحية
البنكيه لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي ولمنظمات
الامم المتحده ليس كل الدول التي تعاهدت
في في في في الكويت في م سواء في المؤتمر
الاول او الثاني الفت اوفت بالتزاماتها
بالكامل في بعض بعض الدول اوفت ونحن لهم
شاكرين جدا طبعا بعض الدول لم لم تنفي
بالشكل الذي لم لم توفي بالشكل الذي الذي
توقعناه وعلى هذا وعلى هذا الاساس تمت
طبعا النقص نقص في التمويل الذي نحن نعاني
منه الان ا سيد صبره يعني هل هل كان هذا
القرار مفاجئا بالنسبه نسبتي لكم ام كانت
لكم تحركات مسبوقه ربما
ل يعني لعدم تنفيذها على الاقل في هذه
المرحله يعني للاسف كان القرار مفاجئا جدا
يعني نحن لم نسمع منظمه الاغذيه العالميه
او المفوضيه الساميه للاجئين لم نسمع منذ
اكثر من من من شهر ان هناك نقصا في
التمويل سيؤدي ربما الى خفض المساعدات
يعني ان ياتي هذا القرار مفاجئا دون ان ي
نقوس الخطر يعني نحن عندما نحمل المسؤوليه
للمنظمات المتخصصه في الامم المتحده فنحن
نقول بان هذه المنظمات هي تملك قاعده
بيانات كامله هي تملك احصاءات هي تملك كل
المعطيات اللازمه عن اوضاع اللاجئين وعن
عددهم وعن اماكن توزعهم وهي تدرك تماما ما
هي التطورات التي ستحدث اذا لماذا لم تدق
هذه المنظمات ناقوس الخطر قبل فتره كافيه
لماذا لم ترفع الصوت وتقول بانني س ددخل
في ازمه ماليه فيما يتعلق بتمويل اللاجئين
السوريين وانني ساضطر الى خفض المساعدات
الغذائيه بعد فتره اما ان نفاجا اليوم
اليوم في ظل وانا اؤكد اتمنى ان لا يكون
هناك وراء هذا القرار اي بعد سياسي اليوم
في ظل كل المعاناه للاجئين السوريين او
النازحين في داخل سوريا اليوم والسوريون
يذبحون بكل ال انواع الاسلحه وبكل اشكال
الحروب اليوم في ظل الانتهاك الضيعه
والمرير للاجئين السوريين في بعض دول
الجوار اليوم يخرج علينا هذا القرار بشكل
مفاجئ دون ان ندري بان هناك ازمه ماليه
تعتري برنامج منظمه الاغذيه العالميه فيما
يتعلق باللاجئين السوريين طيب فقط نتوقف
مع فاصل قصير نعود بعده لمناقشه التاثيرات
المحتمله على اللاجئين السوريين من خلال
هذا القرار نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش قرار الامم المتحده خفض حجم
مساعدتها للاجئين السوريين اعود اليك سيد
صبره اكثر من مره كررت رجاءك
وامنتك بان لا يكون في هذا القرار اي بعد
سياسي ما الذي
تقصده نحن نرى بان الشعب السوري الان فعلا
يحاصر بكل الاشكال الشعب السوري الان يدفع
عندما تقوم بعض الحكومات في دول الجوار
الى محاوله دفع اللاجئين السوريين للدخول
الى الداخل السوري دون تامين المتطلبات
والشروط اللازمه الشعب السوري لم يخرج من
سوريا لانه جائع سوريا كانت تطعم دول
الاقليم الشعب السوري خرج من سوريا بسبب
نظام مجرم مستبد ارتكب جرائم حرب امام
اعين هذا العالم اجمع ولم تتدخل الامم
المتحده في حمايته حق الانسان السوري في
الحصول على ملاذ امن هو حق اصيل مكفول
بالقانون الدولي
وبمعايير لم يخرجوا لانهم كانوا جائعين في
بلادهم نحن لم تضربنا عاصفه لم نصب بوباء
نحن لسنا لسنا ضحايا زلزال نحن ضحايا قضيه
سياسيه اساسيه هي وجود هذا النظام المستبد
الان هناك مضايقات كثيره للاجئين السوريين
في بعض دول الجوار عندما تحرق خيامهم
وعندما يتم الهجوم عليهم بقوات عسكريه وبد
بابات ماذا يعني ذلك وان ي ي قرار الامم
المتحده الان بعد هذه الممارسات واقول
ممارسات في اكثر من دوله حتى لا نخصص بان
الحدث الذي حدث في لبنان فقط في عرسال هذا
ما نخشاه تماما هو التضييق على السوريين
في دول الجوار التضييق على السوريين حتى
في الداخل السوري في المناطق الخارجه عن
سيطره النظام من اجل خيارات اخرى نحن لا
نعرفها حتى الان سيد مهند يعني نبقى في
البعد التقني والاداري لهذا القرار هل
هناك امكانيه للتدارك الان هل هناك فتح ل
قنوات الاتصال مع بعض الدول المانحه ل
تدارك هذا الوضع
الكارثي سيدي قنوات الاتصال لم تغلق الدول
المانحه قد بلغنا وقد دقينا نقوس الخطر
وقد بلغنا الجهات الرسميه من خلال الوسائل
الرسميه طبعا ومن خلال قنوات الرسميه
الدول مانحه تعرف جيدا وضع الشعب السوري
وتعرف جيدا ان اننا نواجه ازمه ماليه فقد
فقد بلغناه وبلغنا طبعا حتى الحكومات في
دول الجوار عن عن موضوع تخفيض المساعدات
الغذائيه فهذا يعني اي ليس مفاجاه كنا
نتمنى ان لا نصل الى هذا القرار وكنا نطمح
ان ان ياتينا ان تاتينا المساعدات قبل
تنفيذ هذا القرار ولكن هذا الوضع الذي نحن
فيه اما طبعا فاكيد نحن لا نزال نعمل على
مدار الساعه مع جميع الجهات اي يعني نوصل
معاناه الشعب السوري ونامل ان تصل
المساعدات وفي حاله وصول مساعدات سيدي
اؤكد لك ان برنامج الاغذيه العالمي سوف
يتمكن من تامين المساعدات للشعب السوري
لحظه وصول هذه هذه المساعدات والطريقه
التي نقدم فيها المساعدات في دول الجوار
عن طريق القسائم الالكترونيه هذه طريقه
حديثه وتمكننا ايضا من تقديم المساعدات
بشكل عاجل فلو فلو وصلنا على سبيل المثال
لو يصلنا دعم مادي الليله في خلال في خلال
24 ساعه 48 ساعه ممكن ان نزيد كميه ال
كميه قسائم الالكترونيه من 20 دولار الى
30 دولار نرجعها كما كانت اذا لم يصل اذا
لم يصل هذا الدعم واذا ما كان القرار
نهائيا ما ما الذي يعنيه عمليا وعمليتي ان
صح التعبير 30 الى 40% تقليص اي يعني حجم
المساعده هي ماساه طبعا هي ماساه للشعب
السوري هي ماساه للاجئين هي ماساه ل
للمشردين الان يعني كما كما سبقت كما
اذكرت اي قبل قليل يعني لا اريد ان اعيد
الشعب الس اعيده الشعب السوري اصبح يعتمد
على على برنامج الاغذيه العالمي الان
نلاحظ احنا اصلا انه بعض ال بعض الاسر ت
تعتمد على وجبتين في النهار بدل ثلاث
وجبات في من كثير من السوريين يشتري
الوجبات التي لا تؤمن لاطفالهم اصلا الدعم
الغذائي الكافي من فيتامينات ومعادن التي
هي الاطفال بحاجه لها للنمو فالوضع هو سيء
ومع تقليل المساعدات من من من سيء لاسوا
وانا من خلال شاشتكم الكريمه ناشد جميع
الاطراف الذين يستطيعون ان يساعدونا في
ايصال هذه الرساله للدول المانحه سواء في
في في المنطقه في في في في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في في دول الخليج في
الدول الغربيه في جميع الدول لتقديم الدعم
فورا لبرنامج الاغذيه الحالمي حتى نتمكن
من وقف هذه هذا النزيف من وق من وقف هذه
المعاناه التي تزداد يوما على يوم للشعب
السوري سيد صبره انت انت لست مرتاحا كثيرا
ربما لتفسير ال المساله على انها فقط نقص
في التمويل وتلمح الى ان هناك
تقاطعات بين ما هو سياسي وانساني في الملف
السوري لو توضح لنا اكثر
يعني يعني كما نرى استاذ الحبيب منذ بدايه
الثوره السوريه الشعب السوري فعلا ترك
لمصيره ترك لقدره يواجه كل هذه الماسي
وحده الشعب السوري عندما طالب بالحمايه
فقط الحمايه حمايه المدنيين حتى يبقى في
ارضه وحتى لا يضطر الى الخروج للبحث عن
ملاذ امن لم تسمع له لا الامم المتحده ولا
الدول الصديقه ولا الدول غير الصديقه
الشعب السوري الان الان وبعد ان حدث الذي
حدث وبعد الحرب على الارهاب الان عندما
يقال لنا بان تكلفه هذه الحرب على الارهاب
هي 15 مليار دولار تاتي منظمه الاغذيه
العالميه لتقول بانه ينقصني 300 مليون
دولار وانا لا استطيع ان اوفرها وبالتالي
ساخف الحصه الغذا ئيه نحن ك كنا نتحدث عن
ان حقوق اللاجئين السوريين في دول الجوار
يتم انتهاكها بالجمله بقي هذا الحق الوحيد
في الحياه الحق في ان يعيش الانسان السوري
في ان ياكل فقط في ان ياكل هذا الحق الان
يراد حرمانه منه نحن اذا فتحنا باب
الانتهاكات حول مساله انتهاك حقوق
اللاجئين في دول الجوار هي مساله فضيعه
فظيعه جدا وكانه يراد ان يدفع الشعب
السوري الى داخل سوريا مره اخرى انا اقول
بان الحرب على الارهاب تقتضي بالدرجه
الاولى تامين الشروط اللازمه للشعب السوري
حتى لا يضطر ان يفقد الامل الشعب الذي
يفقد الامل يتحول الى شعب يائس اليائس
يفعل اي شيء في الدنيا نحن نناشد ليس فقط
نناشد العالم من باب المنطلق الاخلاقي هذا
التزام قانوني على جميع دول العالم يجب ان
لا يحولوا الشعب السوري الى مجموعه من ال
الى مجموعه من الهائمين على وجوههم الزم
هناك من التزم وكان هناك سقف للامم
المتحده لوصول الى مبلغ اكثر من 6 مليار
دولار يعني كا اغاثه انسانيه ولكن الى حد
الان ليس هناك وفاه بهذه الالتزامات
يا سيدي ضمن النظام الداخلي للمفوضيه
الساميه للاجئين يستطيع المفوض السامي
للاجئين المفوض الامم المتحده للاجئين
يستطيع ان يتقدم بطلب من الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده ليوجه نداء من اجل جمع
تبرعات بشكل عاجل هل قام المفوض المفوض
السامي هل قام بهذا العمل اثناء اجتماعات
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده الذي انتهت
منذ يوم هل قام بهذا العمل يستطيع المفوض
السامي للاجئين ان يطالب من المجلس
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي ببعض المعونات
العاجله حتى يسد مجموعه من النقص هذا
النظام الداخلي لمفوضي اللاجئين التي تم
انشائها من قبل الامم المتحده عام 1950
لتواجه مثل هذه الحالات الطارئه نحن نتحدث
عن اتفاقيات دوليه المفوضيه والامم
المتحده الان لا تلتزم بها المفوضيه
والامم المتحده هي تخل بالاتفاقيات التي
وضعتها والتي وقعت عليها والتي تطالب
الدول بالالتزام بها نحن عندما نتحدث عن
الالتزامات القانونيه فاننا نريد من
المفوضيه بالدرجه الاولى ومن الامم
المتحده ان تقوم بواجبها وفق ميثاق الامم
المتحده وفق اتفاقيه
1951 وفق البروتوكول الملحق عام 1967 هذا
ما نريده سيد مهند يعني في هذا السياق
القانون
بهذا المنطق القانوني يعني ربما تعلم ان
هناك يعني قوانين في الكثير من البلدان
تنص على ان عدم اغاثه شخص في خطر ن اسست
دج يعني هكذا تقال بالفرنسيه هو بالنهايه
جريمه السنا هنا في محل جريمه
ايضا سيدي يعني انا لا بد ان اوضح بعض
الامور هي اولا برنامج تغذيه العالمي
والمنظمات الانسان التي تعمل هي منظمات
غير سياسيه ومنظمات غير مسيسه ونحن لا
نسيس لا نسيس برامجنا انا شخصيا كنت في
نيويورك الاسبوع الاسبوع الفائت في في
الهيئه العامه وتكلمنا مع الدول المانحه
وتكلمنا مع الجميع وفاليري اموس تكلمت مع
المجلس الامن انا باكد لك سيدي ان قد قمنا
بواجبنا على على الشكل المراد واكثر من
ذلك ونحن نقوم بدورنا الانساني في سوريا
منذ بدايه الا الازمه وملتزمين تعهدات
ونعرف
دورنا كما كما يجب لكن الموضوع هو ليس
موضوع تقصير من طرفنا هو موضوع مالي بحت
ولازم هذه الحقيقه ف لا بد ان نواجه هذه
الحقيقه اذا اردنا ان نوجد حل لهذه الازمه
التي نحن فيها فل نسمي الامور ب مسمياتها
هذه ازمه ماليه نعاني منها اذا لم تحل هذه
الازمه الماليه فلا حل لموضوع تقديم
المساعدات الغذائيه للشعب السوري هناك
ازمه ماليه يجب على الجميع ان يجب على
الجميع مخاطبه الدول المانحه القريبه
والصديقه والاقليميه لتقديم المساعدات
للشعب
السوري المساله ليست مساله سياسيه ولا دمج
السياسه في في البرنامج الانساني البرنامج
انساني هو برنامج حيادي ليس مسيس واكد لك
ان برامجنا ليست برامج برامج مسيسه
والموضوع فقط هو موضوع نقص التمويل اذا
هذه هي الحقيقه سيد صبره ماذا انتم
فاعلون
نحن الان سنحاول يعني ان نتصل بجميع الدول
الصديقه كما تقول انها دول صديقه سنحاول
ان نتصل لنرى كيف يعني لنرى امكانيه
التزامها بالتعهدات التي قدمتها في مؤتمر
الكويت هناك مجموعه من الدول قدمت جزء من
هذه المساعدات والجزء الاخر لم تقدمه لكن
انا ما اريد ان اؤكد باننا كنا نريد ان
يتم هذا العمل ضمن الاطار القانوني السليم
اي ضمن اطار مفوضيه اللاجئين المجلس
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي للامم المتحده
ومنظمه الاغذيه العالميه لانه هذا ليس
يعني ليس مطلب خاص للشعب السوري نحن عندما
نقول باننا يجب ان نمول برامج اغاثه
اللاجئين السوريين فنحن نعبر عن احترامنا
للقانون الدولي نعبر عن احترامنا للمنظومه
الدوليه ونطاق الامم المتحده هذه ليست منا
للشعب السوري ليست مننا على الشعب السوري
اشر اشكرك جزيل الشكر سيد محمد صبر
المستشار القانوني لوفد المعارضه المفاوض
في جناف رئيس حزب الجمهوريه السوري
المعارض اشكر من عمان مهند هادي المنسق
الاقليمي لدى برنامج الغذاء العالمي
التابع للامم المتحده بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج م وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن
الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد
الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه